[Music]
this is more than just a field of tulips
it's a grieving family's loving tribute
and Lasting Legacy to a Sunday lost in
November 20 year old Ethan Chapin was
one of four college students stabbed to
death in a house near the University of
Idaho Kaylee gonsalves Madison Logan and
Chapin's girlfriend Zana kernodle also
were killed the chapins say their son
lives on in their memories of his smile
immortalized in a tulip field north of
Seattle Lilia Luciano explains
make this yellow oh my gosh yeah look at
wow look at that as they stroll through
this Tulip farm in Northern Washington
State Stacy and Jim Chapin remember
their son Ethan one of four University
of Idaho students murdered almost six
months ago everybody just wanted to be
around you he touched more lives in his
20 years then most people may be
touching a lifetime he was kind he was
inclusive everybody was welcome that
welcoming presence led to lifelong
friendships at tulip Valley Farms where
he worked along with his brother and
sister Hunter and Maisie I think they
parked cars and took out trash and sold
tulips his friends decided to honor
Ethan's memory by creating a tulip mix
in his name they called it Ethan's smile
well Ethan just had a great smile and he
smiled all the time you know and kids
loved it and they said the colors had to
be white and yellow the white reminds us
of his teeth and the smile and the
yellow is bright and cheery and means
French ship
soon the chap and say it seemed many
Touched by Ethan's story okay
wanted Ethan's smile have a good day
sweet the Tulips just became this
tangible thing that that literally the
nation kind of grabbed onto and so we've
gone from there and created a foundation
the Ethan smile Foundation is now
raising money for college scholarships
for students in Washington Skagit Valley
through sales of Ethan's namesake tulips
bulbs and other merchandise I think
there's been over 83 000 bulbs sold I
think there's been over 1300 sweatshirts
sold it's good to see you the chapins
say the support they're getting for
Ethan's smile is helping them cope with
the pain of never seeing their son's
smile again
well I mean it's my honest answer as you
wish you had it back
now I'm crying
is an amazing 20 years we had with him
for CBS mornings I'm Lilia Luciano